bonjour et bonne année à tous et surtout
bienvenue dans cette nouvelle édition d'
europe hebdo version 2013 au parlement
européen à strasbourg
et pour ce premier numéro de l'année
focus sur le mariage homosexuel au
moment où le projet de loi est débattue
en france reportage en belgique où le
mariage entre personnes de même sexe est
autorisé depuis dix ans mais d'abord
l'actualité la france intervient depuis
quelques jours au mali
mais que fait l'europe pour ce théâtre
d'intervention c'est la question de la
semaine
depuis quelques jours déjà les avions de
combat français déchirent le ciel malien
nom de code de l'opération serval face à
une armée malienne exemple les rebelles
ont conquis le nord est ouvert une
brèche vers bamako la capitale
une avancée qui a poussé le président
malien a demandé l'aide de la france
et pendant ce temps à bruxelles
on se réunit on réfléchit on planifie on
continue de préparer l'opération et aux
ut m utm
mais qu'est ce donc une simple opération
de formation de l'armée malienne
prévue depuis de nombreux mois elle est
restée dans les cartons mais premier
juré craché
elle arrive lady ashton haute
représentante aux affaires étrangères
auraient-elles saisi l'urgence de la
situation
pas sûr quant à herman van rompuy le
président du conseil européen il estime
qu'il est urgent de stopper les
terroristes
qui provoque beaucoup de souffrance
parmi la population
un peu court non alors que fait l'europe
pour le mali
alors à l'heure où les forces françaises
sont engagées au mali le se pose la
question aujourd'hui en europe de que
fait l'europe pour pour cette
intervention nous a rejoint sur ce
plateau marielle de sarnez bonjour merci
d'être avec nous vous faites partie de
la délégation paritaire afrique caraïbes
pacifique et l'union européenne
un débat a eu lieu mardi au parlement
sur cette question alors objectivement
aujourd'hui que fait l'europe pour cette
question d'abord si vous me le permettez
je voudrais commencer par dire que ce
qui se passe au mali concerne l'europe
et concerne au fond tous les européens
c'est pas simplement une question pour
mallet pour le mali s'est pas seulement
même une question pour les africains ou
pour le sahel s'est pas seulement une
question pour la france c'est une
question qui concerne la sécurité de
tous les européens et donc c'est très
important que l'europe non seulement
soutiennent politiquement ce qu'elle
fait mais que l'europe montre une
solidarité active c'est à dire en
matière de logistique et en matière peut
être militaire je l'espère demain la
france est en première ligne parce que
nous avons été appelés et vraiment je
soutiens la position française
je soutiens la détermination française
éradiquer le terrorisme de cette partie
là du monde c'est au fond il faut bien
voir que le mali le nord mali est à
quelques pas c'est à l'entrée de l'union
européenne à l'entrée de l'europe
c'était donc vital pour notre sécurité
que de faire ce que nous faisons sur le
terrain mais il faut que l'europe
au delà du soutien politique évidemment
aille plus loin alors justement vous
avez appelé dans l'hémicycle mardi face
à catherine ashton à une accélération du
programme un ut m donc il ya un
programme en fait de formation pour
l'armée malienne
est-ce que ça paraît pas dérisoire
finalement alors que l'armée malienne
est déjà sur le terrain en train de
combat évidemment que ça paraît
évidemment avec beaucoup de lenteur et
que ça aurait été beaucoup mieux que ce
soit fait depuis longtemps puisque ça
fait maintenant plus d'un an que nous
parlons d'une stratégie pour le sahel
ici au parlement européen donc il ya eu
un retard et on voit bien que au fond
l'europe de la défense elle n'existe pas
que l'europe de la sécurité elle est
aussi à construire aussi à bâtir
et que ce qu'il faut bâtir dans les mois
et les années qui viennent ce que nous
cessons de dire nous européens c'est au
fond une robe de la volonté qu'on est
réellement une politique étrangère et
qu'on ait les moyens de défendre les
valeurs dans laquelle nous croyons les
10 h dans le car cette politique
étrangère non mais voilà lady ashton
elle fait ce qu'elle peut c'est à dire
pas grand chose avait cofondé pays qui
gardent leur politique étrangère et je
le comprends il va aussi quelquefois de
l'intérêt national d'un pays mais il
faut en même temps qu'on est une europe
qui pèse davantage
alors heureusement on a quelques pays la
grande bretagne par exemple qui sont aux
côtés de la france est très important
parce que au fond en terme de défense on
a deux pays importants en europe 1 c'est
la france et la grande bretagne que la
grande bretagne soit aux côtés de la
france c'est bien
se pose aussi la question de l'otan nous
sommes rentrés dans le commandement
intégré de l'otan nous équiperons
critique avec françois baldé pas
conseillé au fond nous sommes dans le
commandement intégré de l'otan et que
fait l'otan pour le mani j'attends de le
voir aussi mais il ya aussi un autre
problème c'est que on a affaire quand
même à des critiques par rapport à
l'union vous disiez vous même il ya une
espèce de roc de la défense qui est en
panne on parle d'europe à responsabilité
limitée pardon finalement à quelques
jours d du cinquantenaire du traité de
l'élysée qui vous ya vu la coopération
renforcée entre l'allemagne et la france
l'allemagne est quasi absente de cette
question les soutiens sont strictement
politique tout le monde salue l'action
de la france mais finalement on est
prêtes à un petit soutien logistique un
petit soutien humanitaire soutien
médical
est-ce qu'on a les moyens en france
aujourd'hui d'avoir un théâtre de guerre
comme celui là seule écoute et en tous
les cas j'ai confiance évidemment dans
l'armée française c'est très important
alors ensuite il faut que les européens
à soit aux côtés de cette armée
française il faut que les armées
africaines s'organise alors on voit bien
que tout ça prend un peu de temps mais
enfin on a l'ensemble des pays de la
région qui sont enfin en train de se
mobiliser
on va avoir le soutien aussi américains
c'est très important également notamment
en matière de renseignement et de drones
ces avions qui survolent et qui peuvent
nous dire exactement ce qui se passe
localement
parce que c'est suffisant finalement
objectivement écoutez moi j'assume le
fait que la france soit en première
ligne
ensuite je fais partie de ceux et de
celles qui demandent depuis des années
que l'europe franchissent un pas
supplémentaire pour devenir une vraie
puissance et ben ça ça n'est pas le cas
aujourd'hui ça veut dire ou ne rende à
des causes
ça veut dire en tous les cas une plus
grande et une meilleure coordination en
cas de défense
ça veut dire qu'il faut que l'europe
puisse exprimer avoir une politique
étrangère puisse parler d'une seule voix
et donc ça veut dire quand même un
institutionnel de l'europe et ça veut
dire surtout une volonté affirmée
afficher des chefs d'état et de
gouvernement de considérer que ensemble
nous faisons davantage que séparé en mai
donc ça veut dire aussi abandonner une
part des prérogatives nationales non je
crois que c'est très important l'europe
c'est pas remplacer les dations l'europe
c'est au fond faire en sorte que toutes
ces nations ensemble puisse peser dans
le monde tel qu'il est on a besoin d'un
pôle de stabilité et on a besoin que ce
pôle de stabilité et les moyens de se
faire entendre et de défendre ce en quoi
nous croyons profondément ce qui se
passe aujourd'hui au sahel
ça met en cause pas seulement la
sécurité comme je le disais tout à
l'heure ça met en cause aussi les
valeurs qui sont les nôtres quand on
voit ce que des djihadistes font depuis
des mois et des mois dans cette région
du monde flageller lapider exécuté
condamné nous voyons bien que tout ça
est bien loin de son poids nous croyons
la question du terrorisme c'est pas
seulement une question pour la france je
le dis pour les européens qui nous
entendent c'est une question qui
concerne toute l'europe et tous les
européens et donc oui j'attends que les
chefs d'état et de gouvernement
européens parce que c'est à ce niveau là
que ça doit se passer que ça doit se
déclenche et prennent la mesure de tout
ce qui se passe aujourd'hui au mali et
au sahel alors autre actualité on a vu
l'irlande prendre la présidence
tournante de l'union européenne depuis
le 1er janvier
il a fait partie ce pays a fait partie
des pigs ces cochons de la zone euro
comme on les a appelés un peu un peu
cyniquement ils sont donné beaucoup de
mal exactement et la gagne et je suis
allé deux fois et honnêtement ce qu'ils
ont fait pour se redresser c'est très
bien alors est-ce que vous marielle de
sarnez en tant que vice-présidente du
groupe de l'alliance des démocrates et
des libéraux pour l'europe
est ce que vous êtes confiant dans
l'année 2013 mario draghi le président
de la bce a indiqué qu'il voyait des
signes de reprises pourtant on voit que
en allemagne le pib décroche que
l'italie donne encore des signes de
faiblesse que moi je reconnais que dans
tous les cas pour mario draghi et la
baiss e
ce qu'ils font est extrêmement utile
qu'il y a eu quelques signaux positifs
par exemple une aux bancaires en fin de
l'année dernière enfin on va avoir
peut-être garantie des dépôts bancaires
garanties européennes c'est extrêmement
important et que tout ce qui s'est passé
pendant la crise financière avec les
banques ne puissent pas se reproduire
cet important en même temps on est
encore loin du compte
à la vérité on a besoin de plus d'europe
et de mieux d'europe ça posera la
question d'ailleurs de la démocratie en
europe
les citoyens ont le sentiment que les
décisions européennes entre guillemets
prises à bruxelles finalement c'est pas
leurs décisions en l'europe c'est nous
et donc il faut recréer cette intimité
avec l'europe
ils mettent davantage de démocratie moi
je suis poké un président de l'europe
qui soit président et de la commission
et du conseil et qui soit élue à thème
par les citoyens au suffrage universel
le même jour que l'élection européenne
qui est de zone on vote d'une part pour
ceux qui vous représente au parlement
européen
et puis d'autre part pour ceux qui au
fond vous donner les impulsions
nécessaires à l'europe pour les cinq
années qui viennent on a besoin vital
mans d'une nouvelle démocratie en europe
mais écoutez on est tendance et aussi
une partie du programme de la
présidentielle irlandaise pardon merci
beaucoup de nous avoir rendu visite
nous on continue justement sur cette
présidence irlandaise qui a occupé
beaucoup de nos confrères européens
un petit tour des télévisions étrangères
c'est avec aurélie la face
objectif numéro un
remettre l'économie européenne sur des
rails accord sur le budget coordination
des politiques économiques et union
bancaire programme chargé en perspective
l'irlande pays sauvé dès novembre 2010
assume aujourd'hui la présidence
semestrielle de l'union européenne le
gouvernement enda kenny a six mois pour
essayer de compléter l'union bancaire
une fois les termes de la supervision
unique approuvé il sera essentiel
d'aborder la création d'un fonds de
garantie des dépôts et d'un fonds de
résolution
ce sera la clé pour arriver au plus vite
à la recapitalisation tant souhaitée des
banques sauver la zone euro est une
mission idéal pour l'irlande selon la
télévision allemande
l'irlande et pour la plupart d'entre
nous l'exemple parfait de comment
résoudre une crise européenne et on lui
demande maintenant d'être le régulateur
de l'union le premier ministre irlandais
paraît être un bon leader pour l'union
européenne
parfait pour mener des procédures
complexes comme le fardeau de la
réglementation de rigueur et pour
maintenir l'union soudés dans ses
relations délicates avec le voisin
britannique
mais l'optimisme allemand n'est pas
forcément partagé la présidence de
l'union ça ne parle pas à tout le monde
en irlande section nous avons six mois
pour faire bonne impression dans les
autres pays européens
27 nations je pense que nous avons
l'opportunité espérons le de résoudre la
crise bancaire
de façon générale je pense que ça ne va
rien changer
le pouvoir est toujours en allemagne
et pour évoquer avec nous la présidence
de l'irlande à la tête donc de l'europe
depuis ce 1er janvier c'est jean
sébastien lefebvre qui nous a rejoints
sur ce plateau bonjour vous êtes
journaliste euractiv.fr un site bien
connu qui traite au quotidien des
problématiques européennes alors
l'irlande je les dis auparavant c'est un
membre des pigs les cochons de la zone
euro qui ont eu pour beaucoup donc des
problèmes de dette
est ce que c'est un peu une revanche
cette précède présidence quel est le
programme ps confond irlandais sorti
d'affaires une revanche on peut pas
vraiment dire ça puisque les présidences
sont définis très longtemps à l avance
donc c'est juste le calendrier on va
dire le hasard qui fait qu'aujourd'hui
la présidence revient à l'irlande mais
c'est un signal assez fort parce qu'on a
vu mercredi 7 janvier le premier
ministre irlandais devant le parlement
européen où il a affiché son optimisme
par rapport à la situation irlandaise et
s'est présenté vraiment comme le bon
élève des pays qui ont été sauvés durant
la période 2010 2011 et il a dit
clairement on espère que d'ici la fin de
l'année
l'irlande sortent du de la zone de
turbulences mais surtout du programme de
sauvetage ça veut dire ils ont fini de
faire leurs devoirs et du coup ils
pourront redevenir fiable et aller sur
les marchés cherché chercher directement
le premier ministre irlandais demande
aussi une renégociation de la dette
irlandaise
oui parce qu'en fait ils demandent
surtout que le fardeau qu'ils ont dû
supporter pour renflouer leurs banques
ne soient plus pris en compte dans la
dette de l'état
c'est un petit peu ce que demande chip
aussi actuellement dans le cas des
négociations pour un plan de sauvetage
et les espagnols voudra la même chose
par rapport aux recapitalisations des
banques
parce qu'il faut savoir que l'irlande
n'a pas été sauvée parce qu'elle
abaissait la grèce voilà c'est pas la
grèce avait pas une dette de 150 % en
fait c'est juste qu'elle a dû
jour lendemain trouver 32% de son pib
pour renflouer ses banques et elle dit
comme c'était pour les banques jouent
pas que ça soit dans ma dette publique
suite à l'explosion de la bulle
immobilière effectivement ils ont dû
nationaliser tout cela serve anglais qui
veulent sortir sa de leurs comptes
publics
et c'est un petit peu pourquoi eux ils
vont vraiment poussé sur l'union
bancaire pour mettre en place la
supervision par la banque centrale
européenne est ensuite négocier la
création de fonds communs de dead pour
les banques dans l'est dans les cas
futur mais veulent un petit peu revenir
sur le passé aussi d'accord alors le
programme de la présidence irlandaise
c'est comme on peut s'en douter relance
de l'emploi et croissance au fond c'est
comme d'habitude un peu mais en six mois
ils y feront comme d'habitude je veux
dire gérer les réunions au fur et à
mesure mais surtout ce qui va les
occuper c'est qu'à trois autres gros
dossiers actuellement qui sont là le
budget 2014 2020 de l'union européenne
ce qu'on appelle les perspectives
financières
il faut un accord assez rapidement pour
pouvoir négocier les deux prochains qui
sont la réforme de la politique agricole
commune et la réforme de la politique
régionale et ça il faut que ça est assez
rapidement parce que comme ça doit
rentrer en place le 1er janvier prochain
il faut que le budget soit en gros
décidé pour le printemps pour qu'après
on puisse terminer deux autres réformes
et après les transposer au niveau
national donc on va dire que l'irlande a
aussi intérêt à être un très bon
conciliateur entre les positions des
états les positions du parlement et
jouer un rôle de facilitateur et alors
est ce que l'irlande va réussir à faire
rester son voisin le royaume uni dans le
giron européen on sait que david cameron
doit s'exprimer sur la question est-ce
que
est ce qu'on voit ce qu'on en est à ce
niveau là comment on doit faire son
discours normalement vendredi 18 janvier
l'irlande a pas forcément un grand poids
m'en sépare donc le lien n'est pas dans
schengen en partie parce que son voisin
britannique ne l'est pas l'irlande n'a
jamais eu comme idée de sortir de
l'union européenne encore on a entendu
le premier ministre moment de la prise
présidence a dit on doit beaucoup de
choses à notre intégration à l'union
européenne
ces deux visions totalement différente
donc cameron lui répond à une pression
d'opinions publiques et une partie de
son de son parti conservateur mais on
sait qu'il fera pas de référendum sur
l'appartenance même à mon avis il fera
un référendum éventuellement 2015 2016
mais ça sera plus sûr est ce que vous
voulez qu'on renégocie notre
appartenance les traiter tout ça c'est
la guerre qu'ils puissent négocier
quelque chose mais s'en sortir parce que
c'est pas dans l'intérêt même la city
aujourd'hui commencent à s'inquiéter de
l'idée que le royaume uni pourrait
sortir de l'union européenne donc je
pense pas qu'il ira jusqu'au clash
ultime
merci jean sébastien pour toutes ces
informations on va maintenant dans un
pays que vous connaissez très bien ça la
belgique où là bas le mariage homosexuel
a été légalisé en 2003 sans que cela
pose finalement beaucoup de problèmes
par rapport au débat qu'on peut
connaître aujourd'hui en france donc
avant de retrouver kathia gilder et son
invité direction la belgique avec flora
sauvage
en couple depuis neuf ans à nevers l'ont
choisi de se marier dans quelques mois
ils vont se dire oui devant leur famille
et leurs amis comme n'importe quel
couple depuis 2003 en belgique
le mariage est ouvert à tous y compris
aux personnes de même sexe en en plus
sur 10 quand on a des enfants on voulait
des enfants on va se marier c'est aussi
pour dire aux gens aux amis qu'on a
vraiment choisi pour la pour l'autre
derrière ce mariage d'amour c'est aussi
un moyen de protéger leurs enfants
si l'une ou l'autre des ced pour elle le
mariage est un droit fondamental auquel
tous les citoyens doivent avoir accès
aimer quelqu'un ça n'a rien à voir avec
le sexe avec c'est vraiment aimer un
homme un être humain et même si c'est un
homme ou une femme
il faut être vraiment ouvert et dire
c'est la même chose c'est vraiment la
même chose tu veux que tout le monde
dans le poids pour sa verve et la maman
biologique des deux enfants 6 qui a
trois ans et y est sa petite soeur sont
issus d'un don de sperme
ici en belgique depuis une trentaine
d'années la procréation médicalement
assistée est accessible à toutes les
femmes y compris aux lesbiennes
il n'est pas nécessaire d'être stérile
pour y avoir accès j'étais avec deux du
même nom leur grâce à la loi sur
l'adoption votée en 2006 anna puis
adopter les enfants et devenir leur mère
au même titre que sa compagne on va de
la population
même plus plus important pour nous pour
que la loire de la mariage parce que
c'est vraiment important que le un peu
reconnaît les enfants parce que quand il
arrive quelque chose avec moi qui va se
confirmer en font en belgique dix ans
après le vote de la loi
le mariage homosexuel est entré dans les
moeurs un millier de mariage de même
sexe sont célébrés chaque année ce qui
représente 2 % des unions civiles
en 2003 le sujet n'a quasiment pas fait
débat
plus que le mariage c'est la question de
la filiation et de l'adoption qui ont
suscité des résistances
karine lalieux est députée fédérale
socialiste elle a voté en faveur de la
loi sur le mariage gay les socialistes
et la majorité des partis flamands sur
les partis flamands catholique était
pour directement ouvrir aussi à
l'adoption
mais il ya eu un veto du parti libéral
en disant si adoption il y aura pas de
mariage alors qu'on avait une majorité
pour faire adopter mariage en même temps
nous avons cédé nous avons fait
uniquement le mariage qui était déjà un
premier pas face aux réticences le choix
a été fait de séparer la question du
mariage et celle de l'adoption au siège
de cette association de défense des
droits des homosexuels ou salue l'action
des politiques
c'était une volonté stratégique aussi du
pouvoir politique à l'époque de ne pas
faire passer les deux loin en même temps
donc ils ont attendu quelques années
puis en 2006 ils ont fait passer la loi
sur l'adoption qui étaient intégrés
quelque part aussi à une révision de la
loi qui existait déjà puisqu'ils ont
revu l'adoption intrafamiliales et de
dôngs
or a ajouté que les couples homos avait
aussi droit à l'adoption
l'objectif était de donner un cadre
légal aux enfants vivant dans des
familles homoparentales présents dans
l'hémicycle lors du passage de la loi
sur l'adoption par les homosexuels
ce sociologue raconte comment s'est
déroulé le vote autant le vote sur le
mariage était très consensuel avec le
cas à peu près unique au monde deux
démocrates-chrétiens flamands qui était
dans l'opposition à ce moment là qu'ils
avaient perdu le pouvoir ont voté
majoritairement en faveur de la loi sur
le mariage ce qui est assez étonnant
pour un parti d'origine catholique et
donc la loi sur le mariage et passe
assez facilement la loi sur l'adoption
est passé très juste il malgré les
réticences de certains le débat en
belgique s'est passé dans un climat
apaisé sans aucune manifestation
désormais plus personne ne remet en
cause le mariage ou l'adoption par les
homosexuels
je crois qu'il est important à un moment
donné que le politique en matière
éthique précède la société assume des
choix assume d inventer sociétal même si
l opposition à la société parce qu'on
voit après que s'il ya une normalisation
et bien sale ça calme toutes les
passions la belgique est devenue le
deuxième pays au monde après les pays
bas à légaliser le mariage et l'adoption
pour les personnes de même sexe
l'espagne la suède ou le portugal ont
suivi en europe aujourd'hui sept pays
autorise le mariage homosexuel
reportage signé flora sauvage un autre
pays à légaliser il ya quelques années
le mariage homosexuel c'est l'espagne un
invité est avec nous justement pour en
parler
et pas n'importe qui juan fernando lopez
aguilar
vous étiez au moment de l'adoption de la
loi ministre de la justice du
gouvernement zapatero cette loi
espagnole
vous l'avez un peu porter alors vous
êtes ici aussi le président de la
commission des libertés et de la justice
du parlement européen
revenons à cette époque à 2005
comment s'est passée l'adoption de la
loi est ce qu'il ya eu autant
d'oppositions qu'en france il ya eu bien
sûr de possession mais il faut tout
d'abord rappeler qu'il s'agissait d'un
engagement explicite de la plateforme
électorale avec laquelle on a remporté
les élections en 2004 alors il
s'agissait aussi d'un test de
crédibilité qui est la force des bois
pour changer l'école les choses on a dit
on va établir le mariage homosexuel et
passe en deuxième choix
alors on a fait exactement ça exactement
pour démontrer que les voix allaient
pouvoir dé changer la législation
on a dû expliquer bien sûr qu'en espagne
les droits des mariages c est un conte
sexuelle du mariage civil et des
mariages religieux est toujours
respectée bien sûr mais il y a aussi
dans ce site est ouverte et plurielle d
autres choix qui ont besoin de solutions
législatif c'est que ça que ce manque
quelqu'un qu'on a fait pourtant la
société espagnole est quand même très
catholique
on en peut penser qu'ils aient eu encore
plus de débats et de position qu'en
france est ce que vous comprenez le les
vives critiques qui s'élèvent les les
manifestations en france qui ont il ya
quelques jours vous vous les comprenez
bien sûr l'église catholique a été une
agence d'opposition très forte ensemble
au parti à parti populaire
à la droite et à l'extrême droite en
espagne mais il faut les expliquer il
faudrait expliquer un espagne dans le
code civil
les mariages religieux est respecté et à
des effets civile reconnue par la
législation civile espagnole ça veut
dire que l'espagne est parfaitement
parfaitement légitime dépense et qu'ils
ont c'est marie seulement une fois pour
tout la vie jusqu'à la morte d'avant
dieu ça c'est une choix absolument
légitime mais il y à aussi en espagne d
autres personnes qui ont droit à une
solution législative différents pour
faire des mariages tout simplement un
con trat juridique avec des effets avec
l'une des solutions est sain avec ou
sans discrimination pour récente des
orientations sexuelles sait exactement
comment est ce que vous pensez que le
mariage doit être un droit fondamental
quand comme on l'a entendu avec l'un des
acteurs de ce reportage
des personnes dans l'espagne en fait les
mariages c'est un droit fondamental
protégé par la constitution et c'est
tellement jeu pour chaque aidant une
députation du côté sale de même sexe une
horde attendons une interprétation
extrêmement conservatrice la droite les
partis populaires apporter une écoute
inconstitutionnelle et d'avoir la cote
d'abord la cour des comptes est
constitutionnellement les événements
rapportés récemment cetc cause devant la
cour constitutionnelle parce que la
conséquence de cela a déclaré
parfaitement valide les la constitution
établit espagnol établi les droit
fondamental au mariage sans
discrimination entre l'homme et la femme
est l'essence de cette déclaration
constitutionnelle n'est pas limité les
mariages seulement à l'homme à la femme
et des poupées interdire que il y à des
discriminations à l'intérieur de mariage
et c'est exactement la situation d'avant
de la constitution pendant le franquisme
les fantasmes la dictature franquiste en
espagne la femme perdait ses droits
civils paient pas par l'effet des
mariages c'est à ça c'est interdit par
la constitution mais la constitution
espagnole n'interdit pas que la
législation civile peut établir un
mariage homosexuel à montréal
des personnes du même sexe que c'est que
ce que c'est ce qu'on a fait oui c'est
ce qu'on a fait ce que vous avez fait
puisque vous étiez le
ministre de la justice du gouvernement
qui a fait passer la loi est ce
qu'aujourd'hui elle est entrée dans les
moeurs est ce que plus personne ne s'y
oppose en espagne ou en tout cas est ce
qu'elle est rentrée dans les moeurs la
réponse oui affirme at il pas d'autres
sur sa même à l'intérieur des partis
populaires
même à l'intérieur des forces
conservatrices qui se sont opposés dans
la rue ou dans des manifestations en
déportation faits sont des bruits
l'église catholique tout tout tout le
monde ait pu tout simplement vérifier
que les mariages homosexuels des marins
des personnes de même sexe à l'espagne
et socialement acceptée passé le monde
dans les sondages 60% des jambes de la
population de la société espagnole dit
oui au mariage des personnes de même
sexe mais surtout sur les moeurs sur la
vie quotidienne
on a normalisé ses membres dé vivre
ensemble et se fonde aussi de faire
partie d'une société ouverte aux lianes
et plurielle alors en france quand on a
évoqué la question du mariage on a
évoqué aussi celle de l'adoption est
celle du recours à l'assistance médicale
à la procréation est ce que pour vous
c'est trois questions doivent être
traitées ensemble ou est ce qu'elle doit
faire l'objet de lois différentes en
espagne a eu par exemple des lois
différentes fautes et sur ce sujet où
tout est comment ça se passe non ce
n'est pas les cas on fait il s'agit d'un
question j'aurais dit que même technique
en espagne c'est ce qu'on a fait est
tout simplement modifié l'article du
code civil concernant l'institution du
mariage
on n'a pas touché l'adoption que c'est
un chapitre est tout à fait différent
dont les conti ville
c'est ce qu'on a fait et n'est pas
introduire une discrimination objectif
pour des raisons d' orientation sexuelle
pour interdire des personnes
homosexuelles de faire partie d'une
procédure d'adoption
on a mal géré sans rire à l'assistance
médicale à la procréation et bien sûr ça
veut dire aussi ça veut dire aussi qu'un
espagne où l'on peut faire profiter pour
séduire les options qu'on donne est
célibataire et quand on est marié
quels que soient et quel que soit l'état
monsieur qui soit l'état civil on peut
faire partie d'un pour ceux des dations
alors en espagne il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui ont fait adoption en étant
célibataire
la seule façon des prêts
venir keane couple homosexuel peut faire
parti du président ahmed et interdiront
virtis manque un couple de personnes de
même sexe peut faire partie d'un
postulat d'adoption ça veut dire
attendez une discrimination vis-à-vis
les personnes qui font partie en étant
célibataire
on n'a pas interdit ça alors les faits
ça a été élargir la possibilité de faire
partie des procédures d'adoption on est
à un couple de même sexe
merci beaucoup pour cet éclairage très
intéressant et c'est donc la fin
d'europe et deux on se retrouve la
semaine prochaine à bruxelles avec
françois beaudonnet très bonne suite de
programmes
ciao